[Narrator] Our customers
have made Apple AirPods
the most population
headphones in the world.
And we here at Apple are
now returning that love
by taking our AirPods
to the max!
(intense music)
with the new AirPods max!
They're the AirPods you love, but maximum!
Just try fitting these
in your ears, hot shot.
You can't, they're too big!
And check out these other max
products we've got coming.
Apple keyboard max.
Too big to use.
Apple mouse max.
Not practical.
And check out what we did to Tim Cook.
He's jacked!
Tim Cook Max!
Plus, we did this to a poodle.
(dog barking)
And also this truck.
Truck max!
And the AirPods max sold for $549.
Yes, $549 real actual
American money dollars
is the real actual price.
So you get a free wallet
min with every AirPods max.
The all new Apple AirPods Max.
Sup.
(water gushing)